Any time you want to operate on a bunch
of files that have similar names,
you can use a glob pattern to do it.
I am not making up this name.
Globbing is the real,
actual, technical term for
matching files by name
in the Unix shell.
Seriously, globbing.
If you don't believe me you
can look it up, man glob.
Globbing is a kind of pattern
matching for file names.
When you write a glob pattern in
a shell command, the shell turns
that pattern into a list of file names
that exist to match the pattern.
For instance,
a star matches any string of characters.
You can use a star at the beginning or
at the end of a pattern.
Patterns can be all sorts
of different lengths.
You can use two stars
in the same pattern.
For instance, here, matching every
file whose name contains pp.
A star can appear in
the middle of a pattern.
Matching all the files that
start with B and end with png.
There are other patterns
you can use as well.
For instance,
to match files that end in either CSS or
HTML, a list of strings in curly braces
will match any of the alternatives.
A single question mark
matches any one character.
So BEA question mark dot
png matches both bean and
bear, but it doesn't match beer or bees.
Two question marks matches
two characters, and so on.
List of characters inside square
brackets matches any one of
the characters inside those brackets,
so be and then square brackets
A-E-I-O-U R dot png will match bear and
beer, but not bean or bees.
Something to watch out for
is that file names in Linux are always
case sensitive, and
that applies to globbing too.
For instance, if you have files
that end in jpg in capitals and
files that end in jpg in lower case,
you have to specify which one you want.
If you want both,
you could use the curly braces.